es ist wirklich schlimm ich glaube man
braucht gar nichts dazu zu sagen ich
stehe dir bei peter bruch als rentner 72
jahre alt und er hat uns dieses video
kurz vor der sendung über spielt er
sagen sie nochmal wir stehen jetzt hier
das wasser stand wahrscheinlich jemand
sieht sie hinten noch vor der ersten
etage also eine obersten treppenstufe im
treppenhaus stand das wasser dann und
das ganz bittere ist herr bruch hat
wirklich hier ein eigenheim sich gekauft
das ist auch ab die zahl der wohnt seit
1989 hier und es ist alles abbezahlt und
wenn wir jetzt hier einfach mal schauen
wir gucken mal das ist jetzt quasi der
der hausrat von herrn bruch wir sehen da
schallplatten sagen sie mal was was
liegt da die erste
das ist uns nur die psychologischen
aufnahmen gemacht hatten
und das sind natürlich erinnerungen sie
haben die aufbewahrt und jetzt liegen
diese sachen hier auf diesem haufen was
geht ihnen da durch den kopf wie fühlen
sie sich hilflos und verzweifelt
wir sehen auch hier möbelstücke wir
sehen hier auch reise band ihr der
schallplattenspieler also das ist
wirklich ganz ganz bitter und als ich
hier kam haben wir gesehen wie sie jetzt
hier noch so übrig bleibt und mit dem
wasserschlauch abgespielt haben meinen
sie das wie wird das leben für sie
weitergehen ja ich noch total ungewiss
ob man hier überhaupt noch mal zurück
können dann müssen wir sehen dass wir
ziehen jetzt die nächsten tagen einige
wohnung aber wie der zustand der zustand
des hauses wissen wir ja gar nicht weil
das ist ja das holz konstruktion die
wände sind aufs cover zell und wie die
feuchtigkeit überstanden haben ob man da
noch mal drin wohnen kann wenn sie sich
jetzt was wünschen könnten wie er könnte
ihnen jetzt am besten geholfen werden
haben sie sich schon mal mit der
versicherung in izmir haben wir jetzt
die ersten namen gemacht und haben
gesehen dass mir
das noch retten konnten was zu retten
ist dann sie haben uns nach vorn erzählt
sie haben ganz schnell die sachen das
wasser kam hier ganz schnell nach oben
in den ersten stock gehievt um und
konnten zum glück auch noch so einiges
retten was konnten sie noch hätten die
tiere hauptsächlich portemonnaie oder
brieftasche und sowas handy schnell
gepackt und da sind wir dann raus
gesprungen und dann stand das wasser
schon bewusst hoch und dann wollte ich
noch mal runter gehen was holen
auf der glitschigen treppe ausgerutscht
und lag dann irgendwas halle an und dann
war nichts mehr zu holen nur noch
medikamente alles unten gelassen
in sekunden ist das war die haustüre
aufgesprungen ist und dann kam direkt
ein meter fünfzig wasser rein
blumenkübel von der terrasse große
blumen buchsbäume die rauscht durch die
ganze wohnung sind teil der linken auf
der anderen seite wieder raus geschwemmt
worden
ein top nicht mehr gegen tier da ist
noch der top davon
der ist mir gehen schiemann geknallt und
auch leicht verletzt
und dann sehen wir nur noch auf vom
haben gedacht das was kommt und dann
habe ich mich oben dran gemacht weil mir
ja auch nicht wussten dass es in die
erste etage steht haben dann auch unters
dach in das ausgebaute dachgeschoss dann
versucht noch die nötigsten dinge habe
ich dann den router abgebaut jetzt alles
dann nach oben geschafft was noch zu
retten ist
sie konnten ihre tiere mit auch nach
oben bringen sind also sicherheit wie
geht es ihrer frau ja die ist natürlich
ist auch nicht so beweglich
natürlich nicht so gut wie überhaupt
nicht wie es weitergehen soll noch
verzweifelter und ist ihr zustand also
können sie jetzt nicht schlafen fühlen
sie sich hilflos wollen sie dass ihnen
geholfen oder wollen sie sich erst mal
einen überblick verschaffen
wir versuchen überblick verschaffen und
versuchen es geht uns selbst zu helfen
und schlafen
die erste nach haben wir geschlafen ohne
was zu mehr zu werden
wer so kaputt waren von den ganzen
aktionen also dass die zweite nacht war
das die erste nacht habe ich gar nicht
geschlafen und dann war mir der zweite
nach dem so dachte ich dass wir kamen
noch mein sohn braucht ein katzenklo
weil wir ja nicht schmerzen und ist dann
hier das offene fenster gekommen und wir
haben gar nicht mitbekommen dass er im
haus waren
also herr bruch wir sind natürlich noch
ein bisschen länger hier wenn wir
irgendwas irgendwas ihnen liefern können
dann sagen sie uns wirklich dann
bescheid wir sind noch hier
wir wünschen ihnen alles gute und
versuchen sie das irgendwie zu
verkraften ich kann mir das auch nicht
vorstellen wie es ihnen geht das tut mir
wirklich sehr sehr leid ich habe so
etwas auch noch nie gesehen
ich wünsche ihm wirklich alles gute man
hat ja immer schon mein plan gesehen
denke ich schreibe aber wenn man
natürlich selber betroffen ist ist es
unfassbar